[Music]
so now so it's a huge aircraft carrier
it's a it's a Second World War class
aircraft carrier now now if you look at
that you've never seen another aircraft
carrier it's huge because of course they
landed planes on it today's aircraft
carriers are much larger right and so
but it's parked right there right off of
midtown Manhattan in the Hudson River
and I think they also brought the
enterprise the Starship Enterprise that
would be a hell of a museum exhibit oh
my god so no you mean of course even
though I want it to be the Starship
Enterprise but the Space Shuttle I have
this space shuttle it's the first it's
the very first mock-up of what would
ultimately go into orbit and the
enterprise piggyback mounted on a 747 no
no no they want to so they've mounted on
the back of the 747 right then they
launched it I'm sorry
then the 747 takes off go some very high
altitude and then they explode the bolts
and then this thing does manoeuvres to
come in for landing they were testing
the aerodynamics of it okay of the
fuselage now
I thought so we've never wanted to orbit
but it's the it's it's like the thing
that enabled the ones to go into orbit I
am wary I'm very embarrassed right now
when we found out that we're not getting
one that actually went into orbit a lot
like some city officials complained I to
get on the smack it's like look we got
the first thing that enabled that right
so just check out this there is no - no
that oh I like that what this there is
no vector I like that yeah no I like
like that but here's what's embarrassing
was it I thought that because it cost so
much money to rocket something into
space yes that they would put it on
penny back of a 747 get it up to as
close to the thinnest atmosphere
possible and then from there it would
take off and go into orbit because it
wouldn't take that much fuel no nice try
Chuck okay so a couple things just to
straighten this out go ahead
so 747 can go up to 40,000 feet 45,000
feet all right and how high up is that
that's like eight miles okay the
orbiting Space Shuttle is 250 miles up
okay so that's the imams did not help
but it's not a mouse doesn't do it any
point a bee bee most this is what most
people don't know okay most of the
energy in all of those rockets is not to
get the Space Shuttle up all right it's
to give it horizontal speed so that it
can sustain orbit so the speed that's
most of that energy of the energy event
horizontals me so it's for circling yes
not for ascension right and yet some of
it goes to gate take it up to 230 miles
but what does that take right you drive
230 miles as weather what is that it's
going 18,000 miles an hour sideways
that's where that most of that energy is
going that's why
shortly after it leaves that the the
platform what is it - it does the roll
program and that starts going downwind I
mean down downstream right and so so so
did you ever wonder that well okay it
could just go straight up but then it
would just fall back down to earth when
you hit orbit it is a sustainable thing
that doesn't require your rockets that's
it it's an amazing thing Isaac Newton
figured it out
so Jessop smart guy yeah he was a pretty
smart guy no no he wasn't pretty smart
really the dude was smart he was just
smart flat out no qualifying smarts
right yes so you know he's smart
everybody else might be approaching
smart pretty smart comparative yeah you
have to use you have to modify the word
smart as applied to anybody else right
so it's oh now wait a minute there so
why would it need the rocket speed
if you could sustain orbit just by
falling around the earth using earth
when not using but Earth's gravity just
keeping you in that loop like a
satellite why do you need those Rockets
then no you need the rockets to get to
the point where that can happen by
itself so you got to get to that place
and then you're falling and falling at
17 whatever miles per hour yet 17 17,000
18,000 miles an hour depending how high
up you are okay right
fascinating oh yeah and there's some
where there's a lot of energy that takes
it to go high
so like geosynchronous satellites of
those so the higher up you go the longer
it takes your orbit so the Space Shuttle
Space Station Hubble telescope they take
about 90 minutes to go around the earth
around them okay 90 minutes the higher
up you go takes a little longer you go
higher maybe take two hours okay and
then maybe two and a half hours right
there like four hours in 10 hours and
how there is one orbital distance where
that takes you 24 hours and so lo and
behold that object that satellite will
appear to hover over the same location
of the year because it's traveling along
with the rotation of the earth right it
doesn't care that you the earth happens
to be rotating at twenty once in 24
hours right you get you endowed it with
that orbit earth happens to rotate it
exactly that speed at that rotation rate
and so that's where we put all of our
communication satellites park them above
two places and then you can send signals
up and back and so you're kind of
triangulating the saddle and exactly
exactly step on the fact where they're
parked above the earth things that are
moving at the same time or the end the
same speed that the earth is now I'm old
enough you know I'm old I won't let you
I'm old enough to remember that it was a
big deal on TV when they said live via
satellite that was a thing oh that's
cool that's a satellite today it's like
you know you're on a cell phone talking
to your friend and well now they use
cell phones to actually talk to people
on the news
you know what I mean it's right right
Brett and you have that delay where it's
just like and now we go to Jim on the
spot
with this report Jim and then 35 seconds
later he goes yeah 35 it feels like 35
seconds probably like 3 or 4 seconds so
it takes time you know yeah so if you go
into satellite there's a delay because
they're 22,000 miles up so it's the trip
up and the trip down you process the
signal there's this bit of a delay so
you don't want to use satellites for
witty repartee